I think as Kenny said earlier that I
think we're at the point now that this
has been declared a pandemic that is
it's virtually impossible to contain it
and it's going to become widespread and
also as Kenny said the NBA community is
not immune and so it's going to spread
throughout our community as well what
had happened yesterday was that we had
had a Board of Governors meeting it was
by conference call and some NBA League
committee meetings with some groups of
our owners as well and the very purpose
of the meeting was to decide what our
next step should be I had been talking
to your colleague Grant Hill you know
former NBA great who's also on the board
of the NCAA and he had been filling me
in on their discussions about facing the
decision as to whether they should play
at that point that they have obviously
have canceled at this point but whether
they should play with or without fans
and some of the same experts in
particular dr. Vivek Murthy you used to
be the Surgeon General the United States
under Obama was advising us both and
that the truth is up till a few days ago
or even up until yesterday the experts
were unclear as to whether as a public
health matter NBA arena should be
emptied I think there was a clear
consensus that for people over 70 or
people who have any sort of underlying
ailment or you know it compromised
immunity system that they should not be
coming but again it was an open issue so
we had a board meeting we had scheduled
one for Wednesday and one for today the
purpose of the one Wednesday was so that
we could run through every team and get
their point of view we have some owners
who have fair amount of expertise Micky
Arison who owns Carnival Cruise Lines
who's dealt with these issues for years
you know and others who had who had
opinions and and essentially a
discussion was should we attempt to play
our games without fans in the arena
we'll Rena's would that be safe or we
should take some sort of hiatus and then
the plan was for the league office to
process at that information and then
have another discussion today and make a
decision the call went on for several
hours and I was heading home
around 8 o'clock or so last night and I
got a call from the league office that
we had just learned literally is right
before tip of that Utah Jazz Oklahoma
City game that Rudy Gobert and I'm
almost only saying his name because he
made it public that he was one of the
players that ultimately we learned and
tested positive that although he had
been separated from his team the day
before because he had been running a
fever and once once his tests came back
positive that we needed to make a
decision whether we were then going to
cancel the game and fans were in the
seats ready to go
we were now five or 10 minutes past the
point we were supposed to tip I spoke to
Clay Bennett who was their owner
Oklahoma City Thunder Sam Presti the GM
and also spoke to some representatives
of the Utah Jazz and I think we quickly
agreed that this should not of course be
a business decision we should be
listening to the public health experts
Oklahoma City and the team doctors they
conferred and fairly quickly decided we
should not be playing and then the so
you know I think I officially canceled
the game and immediate issue was
clearing the fan that the building of
fans and not alarming anybody and then
we waited till the fans were out and
then we made that decision since I knew
we had I had had the benefit of several
hours of meetings that day with
representatives of every team on the
issue of a hiatus you know it seemed in
that moment we made the decision that
that at the expression of that last
night's games we should be taking a
hiatus knowing again we would have a
chance to meet and have further
discussions today so that was decision
as you know then we ended up later that
night although reconvening because one
of the referees at the Sacramento Kings
nor on New Orleans game had also been in
touch with the Utah Jazz that referee
had had a prior how about a meeting
earlier in the day with the other two
referees so then we made a decision to
cancel that game as well you know you
know Adam I want to confer a confer with
Kenny and Shaq say man we're so blessed
to have you as a commissioner you made
so many great decisions and I just want
to applaud you on this one because
you know a lot of times in sports money
overrules all common sense but this
thing is so scary we don't know anything
about it you know one thing about NBA
players we're probably the most famous
people in the world and you have so many
kids and so many people coming up are
you asking for autographs taking
pictures with you if a bunch of these
players had to think it could be
catastrophic for a lot of people it's a
great point I mean of course our concern
first and foremost is for the safety of
our players our fans everyone in this
NBA community people working in arenas
and and and and those fans who come to
our games but to your point you know
when you think about a social network
you know we all think of social network
now in terms of the internet and digital
communities but where social networks
begin are people moving around and as
you guys were saying earlier I mean
players if you think one of those maps
in the country of where planes go that's
what players do they move from city to
city and I think that's where from a
public health standpoint they're
particularly focused on them because if
there are clusters of this ailment and
there's a cluster in one part of the
country and then they get up and travel
to another part and when as you know
when they're in those communities
they're in contact with people in the
arena's they're in contact with people
in restaurants hotels and other places
that's how a virus can spread I think
there is a an issue now in terms of how
how quickly this virus is spreading it's
what we have to determine is what if
anything can be done to it not
necessarily stop the spread or slow it
down and again we're relying on the
public health experts what they're
telling us is that even if you can
so-called shift the curve or flatten the
curve and we can push out how quickly
this spreads as a public health net
matter we're doing a service to the
country because particularly for old
people if a lot of people can sit
quickly we're going to quit quick we're
going to run out of resources we're
going to run our respirators ICU beds
etc so that the players are very unique
in that situation because of the social
net
around them you know Adam I think
overall you know what I think we all
have admired at all we recognizes part
of leadership is having a clear
derivative and a clear direction so for
me my question would be what is the
clear direction to say this is going to
make us play again so what is that way
what are we looking for for that to
happen yet you know right I just say you
know back to Charles's point in terms of
our direction when in the to sort of
full board meetings I had yesterday and
today not one team raised money but it
the entire discussion was about the
safety and health of the players the
community around the NBA and our fans
and so of course the issue becomes now
you know we what what we determined
today is that this hiatus will be most
likely at least 30 days I mean it and we
don't know enough as you've all said to
be more specific and men specifically
Matt but we wanted to give direction to
our players and teams and to our fans
that this is going to be roughly at
least a month but then the question
becomes is there a protocol frankly with
or without fans in which we can resume
play and I think the goal and been
talking a lot to Michelle Roberts the
Players Association just talk to Chris
Paul the president of the union again
earlier night and you know and coming
together what's what makes sense here
and without compromising anyone's safety
and I think it's frankly too early to
tell again it depends how quickly this
virus spreads and it also depends on
what the theory is going to be and how
to treat it it we may get fairly quickly
to a point you guys were mentioning flu
earlier where well based on everything
we know this is significantly more
serious than the common flu at least in
the United States it we may ultimately
get to a point where it's treated by
treating symptoms and those who are sick
rather than this for a quarantine
containment strategy and that would mean
for example if a player was running a
temperature or you Charles like for
example were we're not feeling well you
would treat that player you wouldn't
necessarily then
quarantine the rest of the team so that
is something we have to look at again
we're conferring with all the experts
and we also recognize that because of
how high-profile our players are that
others in the public will take their
lead from us in fact you know we don't
talk a lot about it and Rudy Gobert has
acknowledged that he made a huge mistake
by fooling around and touching the mics
and all doing that the other day when he
had no idea that he had the virus and
something we spoke to him today in fact
about doing a public service
announcement with the league just
because we know the public follows what
these players do and we want to make
sure people understand how important the
protocol is of washing your hands
thoroughly for 20 seconds of you know
you know you know not not you know
touching your face you know after you've
watched you washed your hands about
maintaining social distance in a certain
situation so we actually think we can
use this hiatus to use this platform we
have on social media to help people deal
with this disease so when you were
making the decision last night you used
the word
suspend what was your thought process in
saying okay we're going to suspend the
rest league as opposed to cancel the
rest of the season the thought process
first of all I mean this was a
split-second decision so that was the
word I chose in the moment it may be a
better word that could have been used
but I also felt the same time that given
unlike you know the Final Four which is
the month of March as you guys well know
our season you know goes well into June
and I was also thinking at the time and
and I had talked to our television
partners folks at Turner you know and
NES punic about ABC about possible
contingencies we recognized that there
was there was a chance we might be
stopping the season and I think
everybody especially in a crisis like
this would indicated absolute
willingness to work together again in
her and we had already met yesterday
with the Players Association as well
before we knew anything about a positive
test so so my thinking shock was you
know even if we're out for a month
even if we're out for six weeks we could
still restart the season you know it
might mean that
and the finals take place in July you
know late July just my feeling was it
was it was it was way premature to
suggest that we had lost the season it's
and and again I you know it's it may
seem odd at the same moment that we're
saying for health reasons we need to
take a break to talk about restarting it
and that the notion of at least 30 days
was just to try to give people some
guidance I mean it I I'll say one thing
it's remarkable to be here talking to
you guys tonight about this hiatus when
it was only yesterday that the that
first the n-c-double-a made that
decision to play without fans which
seemed you know it was unprecedented was
a unprecedented was a historic decision
and we were having the same discussion
to be jumping here one day later and I
think it only makes the point that on
this issue and all the things we've all
dealt with for so many years you know
you could say well it changes day by day
this literally changes hour by hour in
terms of what we know so it was really a
moment for us to step back take a breath
ensure that everyone in the NBA
community was safe and healthy and doing
everything they needed to do to care for
their families and then let them give us
some time to deliberate and figure out
if there's a way that we can resume
playing at some point adam is it
possible that the season will not
continue of course it's possible I I
mean I I I just don't know more at this
point I mean there's another factor
which and may that may go to the
seasonality of this virus again you know
talk to a lot of experts a little clear
some have a theory that as it's just as
with the common flu as the season as
that as the weather changes we may see
it begin to peter out a little bit I
mean again we don't know so you know at
this point we're just we're just waiting
you know we one of the things we want to
do during this hiatus and this is one of
the things I had a meeting with our
general managers and team presidents
late this afternoon by conference call
to talk about how are we going to use
this time decisions as to whether the
players will stay in market I can
understandably some of the players play
and you may play in a market but their
families may live in another city will
they be rejoining their families what's
the best way to keep them them safe
you know what what's the best way to
keep them in shape you know all those
things are still on the table because
this has happened so quickly Adam you've
been more than gracious with your time
tonight we truly appreciate it can't
thank you enough and we'll stay in touch
and and again well done on doing
something that's nobody wanted to see
but nobody can really argue with given
the magnitude of this situation so thank
you very much